winter is coming and if you're not
scared yet you better get that way quick
beyond the wall Game of Thrones season 7
episode 6 the penultimate episode of
this sadly shortened season and oh boy
ok look I like this episode I like it a
lot
but I'm not going to sit here and wax
the car this thing the whole way through
there's actually a lot of things that I
some things that bug me some things that
maybe won't bug me depending on how the
rest of the season pans out and some
things that I'm going to nitpick on and
I feel really bad doing this because I
know how well this episode's been
received and how much everybody is
praising it so what to do because I'm
gonna have to talk about this stuff you
know what let me let me be clear about
one thing pretty much everything that
happens beyond the wall I liked or loved
most of the stuff that isn't taking
place beyond the wall bugged me for one
reason or another and not just because
it was cutting away from the much better
more compelling stuff so that probably
didn't help but just individually all
those scenes for one reason or another I
annoyed me I'm gonna start having said
that and realizing I'm going to come
back to praising the stuff that is
awesome let me start with the stuff that
I have issue with um Aria is annoying me
which is a first I get it from a
completely character standpoint I get it
but it is annoying to me as a viewer to
see her holding as a grudge against
Sansa stuff that happened five years ago
and I grant that you know that is
because I have knowledge that Aria
doesn't because I know explicitly what
happened - Sansa what was happening to
her at the time that she wrote that
scroll and what had happened to her
since then and Aria doesn't not in great
detail and I again
logically I understand that but it
doesn't make it any less annoying to
watch her holding this grudge against
her sister that with what I know I can't
help but feel is unearned and it also
makes that all the more aggravating
knowing that is playing into little
fingers hands because while I said he
irritates me in a fun way I don't like
seeing people play into his hands
because that kind of makes them look
dumb I don't I want him to progress by
him being smart not by other people
being dumb and that's kind of how it
feels right now with what's going on
with this because then Sansa runs off to
control with a little finger actually do
a degree that seems inconsistent with
how aware she was of how dangerous and
untrustworthy he is um and again I I did
it I understand that she just felt like
she was emotionally stabbed in the back
by her sister she doesn't have a ton
people to feel like she can turn to
that's still really frustrating to me
because I know it's exactly what he
wanted yeah it's frustrating in a way
that isn't fun for me and I feel like
the show may have overstepped if it was
trying to make me not always be on arias
side which I suppose is not an
unreasonable goal I mean what she has
been doing lately has been incredibly
grim and maybe I shouldn't be as yeah
Aria as I am I'll grant that but this if
they're trying to mitigate that I think
they overcorrected in terms of how she
behaves this episode and just me not
liking it not feeling it not digging it
Daenerys is bugging me in this episode
do she feel she's doing and I've Todd
mentioned this before she's yo-yoing
again she keeps seeming to start to
mature and then backpedal cuz she did
she feels very childish in this in terms
of the stances she takes when talking to
Tyrion and when I look at her the season
overall like this insistence that the
world is black and white or that she's
got to somehow force the world to be
black and white it just feels
like a much less mature point of view
then she had not all that long ago I
mean what was the point of all the stuff
in marine with her coming to understand
that even the slavers had people who
cared about them and were dependent on
them well I mean what was the point of
that scene with that guy saying my
father wasn't so everybody was a good
man but you killed him what's the point
of those scenes if the growth that she
seemed to take from that is going to be
negated a season or two later that that
irritates me so like I said the stuff
that isn't actually happening above
beyond the wall that all that stuff
bothered me for one reason or another
of course the substance actually going
on beyond the wall itself pretty awesome
pretty dang awesome this episode did a
really good job of getting these
characters in positions whereas like ah
you know get a few of them got some nice
highlight moments that maybe didn't have
them before I feel like I've gotten to
know Varrick a little bit better here
than I did before
now we had a really nice moment between
Jorah and john before you know
everything started going down and boy
once things start going down they go
down hard and there's a lot of tension
in that mole in those moments where
they're stuck in this little island with
the ice around them just wood surrounded
by the dead they held up a lot but I am
surprised we lost as few characters as
we did it really was just you know
topknot brother without banner dude he
was pretty much the only one we lost
well that and a dragon but I mean it's
like I said it's awesome it's epic it's
tense and as it went along it I want to
say that this stuff was predictable
because it wasn't I didn't call any what
was going to happen before the episode
started but as the episode was
progressing most of what happened
I called mmm two to five minutes before
it happened
as soon as the night's king went for one
of those beers I'm like he's taken down
a dragon and I called it and then
soon as that dragon started coming I'm
like we're going to have a zombie dragon
by the end of this episode so I called
that well in advance of a happening I
called that Benjamin was going to be how
John got out of the situation so there's
a lot of beats that I think we're really
telegraphed but they just felt like the
very very much the logical thing that
was going to happen and that's not
necessarily a bad thing and it was all
well executed of the one thing I did not
call I was dead certain torment was not
going to make it alive from this I mean
I kind of pegged him as likely to die
before but I was dead certain as this
episode went on cuz he's talking about
he's he's crushing on Brienne and he's
talking about that with the Hound which
was another great moment by the way and
you know he mentioned I was that babies
with her my dude you might as well be in
a cop movie and say you've only got two
days to retirement but yeah I was so
certain you know he's got almost a jobs
movement where they're like pulling him
down and recovered man Keith I think I
think he gets the the tough bastard
metal for this one although John might
take the silver on that category and I'm
also slightly disappointed that the fact
that both beric and John the fact that
they have come back from the dead in no
way factored in to their interactions I
said before that I thought it would and
think about it
it struck me flat-out odd that is in no
way impacts anything I mean that you
think that would have some relevance and
to me it's weird that it didn't and it
might end up going down as kind of a
missed opportunity for me and how god
I'm going to get so slammed in the
comments and so down but on this because
I'm making it sound like it didn't like
the episode I did like the episode I
liked the episode awash but the things
that are great about this episode
everyone knows what they are everyone is
already seeing the praises of all the
things that are great in this episode
and I just feel like it's not it's not
the best thing ever
I actually thought spoils of war was a
slightly better episode than this was
but look this is this is like a solid
eight out of ten kind of episode I don't
do numerical ratings as a rule of thumb
and I'm not going to start doing them
but I'm just trying to to make the point
this is very good and when it is rousing
and puffy in urine ah it's great it's
terrific and I loved the experience of
watching it it was just what it was done
I started picking at it and I can't help
it
I I just I can't I'm sorry but I mean
look the action stuff is right up there
with hardhome and with the Battle of
Blackwater and the assault Lola is right
up there with the greatest action
spectacles that this show has offered so
you know absolute props of that is a
great way to set up a finale episode I'd
be really excited to see what happens
next so despite my having spent the
majority of the runtime of this video
pointing out stuff that annoyed me or
bothered me please different accuse me I
didn't like this episode I like it a lot
this is just the stuff that's stuck in
my head up a little bit more for
whatever reason I'm a grumpy bastard
sorry so those are my thoughts on the
latest episode of Game of Thrones what
are your thoughts whatever they are
dropped me down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget the like
subscribe check me out on Twitter I
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]